In 1992,
Congress passed legislatio
making the month of May
Asian Pacific American
Heritage Month.
And here to help you celebrate
this month properly
is one of our writers --
Karen Chee, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, everybody. Seth is right.
Asian Pacific American
Heritage Month
was established 27 years ago
but people still don't quite
know how to celebrate it.
So if you're a white perso
trying to join in on the fun
I've got some do's and don't
for you.
Number one, don't ask me
where I'm really from.
Because when I say I'm fro
a suburb of San Francisco,
I can tell you're disappointed
Asian-American people
are descendants
of many different countries,
which is just a polite way
of saying,
number two,
don't say "Ni hao" to me.
Just because I'm Asian
doesn't mean I speak Chinese
I don't walk up to every white
person I see and assume
that they know where
the nearest Williams-Sonoma is
I mean, they do every time..
but I don't just assume.
Number three, do bow to me
[ Cheers and applause ]
But it's not because I'm Asian
It's just because
I'm cool as hell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number four, don't ask me
what my real name is.
It's Karen. I don't have
a secret Asian language name
And even if I did,
I wouldn't tell you.
Because it's a secret.
Number five, don't ask me
what your tattoo says.
I can't tell you what it says.
But I can tell you
what it means --
you make bad choices.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, do buy me a drink
It's just a stereotype
that Asian people
can't drink alcohol,
but we drink all the time!
Hell, I'm drunk right now!
Anyway, so, back to you, Seth.
Or as we say in my country
"Back to you, Seth."
-Give it up for Karen Chee
everybody!